avant d'en venir à ce texte je me dois
d'abord de vous communiquer les excuses
de la présidente madame Fadila Khattabi
qui avait enfin de matinée un échange
avec les organisations syndicales de son
département et qui nous rejoindra ce
soir
762 amendements ont été déposés sur la
proposition de loi
31 ont été retirés par leurs auteurs 10
ont été déposés en double et deux
présenter divers motifs 10 recevabilité
la présidente a par ailleurs suivi la
vie du président de la commission des
finances qui considère que 164
amendements contreviennent au
dispositions de l'article 40 de la
Constitution et un au disposition de la
lolse
enfin la présidente s'est efforcée
d'assurer le respect des dispositions de
l'article 45 en favorisant le plus
possible l'initiative parlementaire la
proposition de loi porte prioritairement
sur les problématiques d'accès aux soins
d'organisation territoriale des soins et
d'engagement sur le territoire des
acteurs de santé
la présidente a donc considéré que
devait être examiné les amendements
portant sur ces thématiques dans leur
dispositif comme dans leur intention
dès lors 44 amendements ont été déclarés
irrecevables au titre de l'article 45 il
s'agit par exemple d'amendement tendant
à supprimer la récupération d'un dus par
la Sécurité Sociale
créer une formation à la santé visant à
l'acquisition de compétences d'autosoin
à tous les stades de la scolarité
faire de l'espérance de vie en bonne
santé un objectif de la politique de
santé nationale
fixez comme objectif de santé publique
la progression de deux années de
l'espérance de vie
donner à l'ordre des médecins un rôle
prépondérant dans la procédure
d'agrément des centres de santé
demandez des rapports sur l'opportunité
d'ouvrir de nouvelles négociations
conventionnelles pour les infirmiers
libéraux sur l'état des lieux du suivi
médical des résidents en EHPAD ou sur
l'évolution des rémunérations des
internes de médecine je passe donc
maintenant la parole aux rapporteur
Monsieur Frédéric Valtou
merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues mesdames et messieurs trouver
des solutions concrètes à la crise
actuelle de notre système de santé tel
est l'objectif de la proposition loi que
nous a nous apprêtons à examiner en
ville comme elle à l'hôpital il nous
revient de définir une meilleure
organisation territoriale des soins en
incitant à une plus forte coordination
des acteurs de terrain alors où la santé
et la préoccupation principale des
Français comme le montre régulièrement
toutes les enquêtes d'opinion nous nous
devons d'agir autant rapidement qu'en
cherchant l'efficacité il est ainsi de
notre responsabilité de résoudre cette
question lancinante c'est difficile de
l'accès aux soins de nos concitoyens qui
malheureusement font les frais de
l'accumulation de plus de 20 ans de
décision politique administrative
malheureuse d'un manque réel
d'anticipation est parfois des aides de
la force des habitudes on a
conservatisme exacerbé de nombreux
acteurs depuis des années comme d'autres
j'ai pu constater que notre système de
santé se caractérise par son extrême
centralisation parfois ça
sud-administration mais aussi son
extrême cloisonnement entre les
professionnels contraint par des statuts
juridiques et des modes de commencement
rendant souvent difficile les
coopérations aujourd'hui le temps est
venu de faire confiance aux acteurs de
terrain à tous ceux qui directement les
professionnels de santé comme
indirectement les administrations de
l'État ou la ou de la sécurité sociale
les collectivités locales les
associations de patients notamment bref
tous ceux qui concourent à la prise en
charge des Français en matière de santé
et sont partis prenantes de cette
question de l'organisation des soins la
crise épidémique que notre pays a
traversé en même temps qu'elle a montré
le besoin d'objectifs nationaux
clairement posé par l'État a rappelé la
force des initiatives et des
coopérations pensées dans les
territoires comme d'autres je suis
convaincu que l'avenir d'un système de
santé passe par notre capacité à
accompagner des modes d'organisation
dans la prise en charge de nos
concitoyens réfléchis au plus près du
terrain adapté aux spécificités de
chaque territoire et aux besoins de la
population heureusement nous ne partons
pas de zéro la territorialisation des
politiques de santé est un virage pris
sur le plan politique depuis quelques
années notamment sous le précédent
quinquennat il y a d'abord eu la réforme
ma santé 2022 en 2018 qui en avait posé
les jalons cette réforme posée par
exemple entre autres mesures la
reconnaissance du principe de
responsabilité populationnelle des
acteurs de santé c'est-à-dire la
reconnaissance que ces derniers sont
collectivement en charge de la
population qu'il servent et qu'il faut
privilégier les moyens dont ils
souhaitent se doter pour y faire face il
y a aussi le texte récent porté par ma
collègue Stéphanie irist portant
amélioration de l'accès aux soins par la
confiance aux professionnels de santé
qui constituent une pierre utile dans la
perspective d'un décloisonnement de
notre système de santé dans une
continuité d'approche avec cette volonté
de pousser plus loin la
territorialisation de notre système de
santé la proposition loi que nous allons
discuter a aussi pour vocation
d'inscrire dans le droit positif les
annonces récemment formulées par le
Président de la République notamment
lors de ses vœux aux soignants début
janvier meilleur partage des efforts
entre tous les soignants par exemple en
matière de permanence des soins
décloisonnement entre tous les modes
d'exercice ou encore volonté de faire
confiance dans les soignants pour faire
émerger des stratégies en santé adaptées
aux besoins de chaque territoire
cette propositions loi visent aussi à
concrétiser la déclinaison dans les
territoires de l'approche mise en avant
par le CNR santé sur la consolidation de
la permanence des soins notamment où
l'émergence de stratégies territoriale
via les conseils territoriaux de santé
ou le coût d'accélérateur donné aux
communautés professionnels de
territoires de santé vous l'aurez
compris la souplesse le dialogue la
coopération et la mobilisation de toutes
les énergies dans les territoires ces
riches comme le fil conducteur de ce
texte
avec 12 dispositifs territoriaux en
matière de santé qui s'interposent entre
le cabinet du médecin et l'Agence
régionale de santé notre système a
besoin de retrouver de la simplifie de
la simplicité et de la lisibilité pour
retrouver de l'efficacité tel est
l'objet des deux premiers articles du
texte qui tendent à faire du territoire
de santé le périmètre de référence de la
déclinaison localement des politiques de
santé ces territoires de santé seront le
lieu de la pérennisation des CNRS
territoriaux l'article premier prévoit
ainsi que le conseil territorial de
santé prennent corps en ayant la
responsabilité de la définition des
objectifs prioritaires du territoire de
santé tels que les besoins de couverture
territoriales en permanence des soins ou
la juste répartition des forces
médicales dans son territoire rappelons
que ce terrible conseil territorial de
santé qui réunira l'ensemble des partis
prenantes n'est pas une création de ce
texte puisque son cadre légal a été posé
par la loi moderne le modernisation de
notre système de santé de 2016
aujourd'hui c'est une coquille souvent
vide demain il sera le lieu où s'élabore
on collectivement les stratégies locales
en de santé le dispositif proposé
affirme en effet le caractère collectif
de la responsabilité des professionnels
de santé de plus le texte prévoit de
responsabiliser les acteurs de terrain
sur la nécessaire réduction des
inégalités de densité démographiques
ceci est primordial à l'heure ou plus de
1,6 millions de nos concitoyens
renoncent chaque année à des soins
médicaux ou plus de 11% d'entre eux
encore n'ont pas de médecins traitant
associer l'ensemble des partis prenantes
d'un territoire dans l'élaboration du
projet territorial de santé est
également fondamental tous les acteurs
élus préfet directeur généraux d'Ars et
leurs services représentant des
établissements sanitaires et
médico-sociaux et libéraux au sein des
CPTs tous doivent orienter et coordonner
la politique locale de santé sur le
territoire c'est le sens de la
disposition qui élargit la composition
du conseil territorial de santé nous
voulons aussi renforcer les dynamiques
de coopération et d'organisation
territoriales on nous appuyant sur ce
qui a pu être fait pendant la crise du
covid-19 c'est pourquoi l'article 3 vise
à rattacher automatiquement les
professionnels de santé
professionnels de santé et les centres
de santé à une CPTs du territoire auquel
ils appartiennent il existe aujourd'hui
environ 800 communautés professionnelles
de territoires de santé avec des niveaux
de développement très hétérogènes la
mesure que je propose permettra
d'accélérer leur déploiement elle
résonne avec la volonté exprimée par le
Président de la République à Vendôme que
d'ici la fin de l'année tout le
territoire soit couvert par une CPTs et
ce dans le respect du choix de pardon et
ce dans le respect du libre choix de
chaque professionnel de s'inscrire ou
pas dans cette dynamique à travers la
possibilité qui lui est reconnue de sa
franchir de cette intégration je sais
combien l'amélioration notre système de
santé ne peut se faire sans une refonte
du dispositif de la permanence des soins
en établissement de santé la loiriste en
a posé les bases en inscrivant le
principe de la responsabilité collective
garantissant l'accès en ambulatoire à
toute la population nous devons
désormais mettre en oeuvre cette
responsabilité collective pour la
permanence des soins en établissement il
convient ainsi de réduire la pression
sur l'hôpital qui est trop souvent la
seule lumière allumée sur le territoire
même si je n'oublie pas que 40% des
généralistes pour l'ambulatoire assurent
eux aussi les gardes la permanence des
soins devant être l'affaire de tous les
professionnels nous devons rééquilibrer
le dispositif entre le secteur public et
le secteur privé c'est toute l'ambition
de l'article 4
le maintien de l'offre de soins dans un
territoire donné doit aussi passer par
une meilleure intégration des praticiens
formés hors Union Européenne une réforme
de leur statut a été votée en 2019 mais
encore aujourd'hui c'est praticiens
indispensables à certains services
rencontrent des difficultés pour obtenir
un poste les articles 9 et 10 proposent
de faciliter leur exercice en prévoyant
de nouvelles autorisations d'exercices
provisoire et une nouvelle carte de
séjour plus annuelle
encourager la titularisation des néo
diplômés qui tendent à s'installer de
plus en plus tard est également prévu
dans cette proposition de loi l'article
7 vise à interdire l'exercice de
l'intérim en début de carrière dans les
établissements de santé médico-sociaux
ainsi que dans les laboratoires de
biologie médicale cette mesure permet de
lutter contre les excès de l'emploi
temporaire qui font qu'il est de plus en
plus difficile de recruter sur des
postes pérennes aussi bien dans les
établissements de santé d'ailleurs que
dans les cabinets de ville
mais mes chers collègues transformer
notre système de santé doit aussi nous
conduire à nous attaquer à certaines des
difficultés qui rongent notre hôpital
public si l'instauration des groupements
hospitaliers territoires en 2009 a été
un véritable big bang d'organisationnel
pour le secteur hospitalier ces derniers
n'ont pas toujours correspondu aux
réalités territoriales l'article 6
permettra au groupement spécialité
territoire qui ont atteint une maturité
suffisante d'acquérir une personnalité
morale ce qui simplifiera la conduite de
projets à l'échelle du groupement il est
également proposé d'étendre les
compétences du Conseil de surveillance
pour en faire un véritable lieu de débat
sur la gestion et l'offre de soins de
l'hôpital en lien avec le territoire
enfin dans le sillage de l'affaire ORPEA
l'article 8 renforce le contrôle
financier sur les cliniques privées leur
satellites et les sociétés qui les
contrôlent ils tend élargir le périmètre
des institutions en mesure de les
contrôler dans un contexte où les
agences régionales de santé n'ont ni les
moyens ni l'expertise pour tout faire
pour conclure j'ai la conviction que les
mesures portées par ce texte permettront
d'apporter certaines solutions concrètes
aux enjeux actuels de notre système de
soins en ville et à l'hôpital il est
urgent d'agir maintenant pour améliorer
l'accès aux soins par l'engagement
territorial des professionnels je tiens
à remercier l'ensemble des personnes
auditionnées telles que les
représentants des médecins des
infirmiers des étudiants les ordres des
professions de santé les représentants
des élus locaux les fédérations
hospitalières pour leur collaboration et
leur contribution nous nous devons de
prendre en main la santé de nos
concitoyens qui sont les premiers
perdants face à un système de santé
aujourd'hui à genoux je remercie aussi
mon groupe horizon ainsi que les 200
députés cosignataires de cette
proposition de loi pour leur confiance
et leur soutien merci beaucoup
oui merci monsieur valetout nous allons
maintenant passer à l'expression des
représentants des groupes politiques je
donne la parole à Monsieur Jean froissa
Jean-François excusé moi Rousset du
groupe Renaissance merci
madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur chers collègues nous
partageons tous l'essentiel du
diagnostic l'offre médicale n'est pas
suffisante chacun dans sa
circonscription le constate nous
manquons de médecins nous manquons de
soignants 700 000 malades ayant une
affection de longue durée non pas de
médecin un million 600 000 Français
renoncent chaque année
jusqu'en 2018 le nombre de médecins
formés étaient limité tous les ans par
le numerus clausus après des années de
terre vigie tergiversation nous l'avons
supprimé en 2021
1675 étudiants ont été admis en deuxième
année de médecine soit plus 24% par
rapport à 2018
dans l'intervalle entre le moment où
nous avons supprimé le numérique
explosus et le jour où ces jeunes
médecins exerceront nous prenons toutes
les mesures organisationnelles qui nous
semblent adaptés mais nous souhaitons
surtout éviter toute mesure
contradictoires en particulier celle qui
entraînerait une perte d'attractivité
sur ses professions déjà en tension
c'est le cas de la régulation de
l'installation nous y reviendrons
détails tout au long de nos discussions
mais je le dis d'emblée toutes les
études internationales concluent à
l'échec de cette mesure c'est un rapport
du Sénat qui le dit ce n'est pas nous
c'est aussi la conclusion des travaux de
l'adresse pire les dernières enquêtes
sur les jeunes médecins nous indiquent
qu'en cas de coercition 10% d'entre eux
partiraient à l'étranger et en grand
nombre de ceux qui exercent en France
choisiraient d'aller vers des
entreprises qui convoitent leurs
compétences par exemple les laboratoires
en tout cas il n'exerceront pas la
médecine générale dans nos communes donc
prudence vous le savez comme moi les
mesures faciles évidentes sont rarement
les plus efficaces elles font plaisir à
dire elles donnent l'impression d'une
réponse rapide mais cette réponse aura
des conséquences dramatiques similaires
à celles que nous subissons maintenant
depuis le vote du numerus clausus dans
les années 70
nous nous n'agissons ni sous le poids du
corporatisme disant ni dans une logique
démagogique l'objectif que notre groupe
est d'obtenir des résultats pour
retrouver le plus vite possible maximum
dans nos communes c'est pourquoi le
groupe Renaissance votera cette
proposition merci Monsieur Rousset
Monsieur Thierry frappé pour le
rassemblement national
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur chers collègues l'ensemble
des lois relatives à la santé dont nous
avons débattu amène toute un constat
simple la situation actuelle dans
l'offre des soins se dégrade il faut
agir si ces lois veulent répondre aux
besoins existants elle négligent
l'urgence de la situation dans laquelle
se trouve nos concitoyens le manque de
professionnels sur le territoire votre
première tentative de loin sur l'accès
aux soins pour tous à 1000 et syndicats
de médecins dans la rue
avez-vous compris la colère des
professionnels tirant la sonnette
d'alarme face aux difficultés
quotidiennes de leur exercice faisons le
constat 6 millions de Français sont 100
médecins traitant généraliste alors que
ces derniers travaillent en moyenne 55
heures par semaine et que 51% de ces
médecins présentent des signes de Burn
Out est-ce alarmant évidemment
ajoutons 20 à 30% de charge
administratives une augmentation inédite
des agressions déclarées et de plus en
plus violente sur l'ensemble des
professionnels de santé la loi proposée
est un cocktail de bureaucratie ignote
ignorant tout excusez-moi du travail de
praticien de santé surcharge
administrative et vous voulez créer un
centre territorial de santé qui
proposait sur les professionnels
installés la responsabilité collective
de l'accès aux soins vous rendez
obligatoire l'adhésion à des CPTs au
mépris d'une droit commun des contrats
et de l'idée initiale d'une adhésion
volontaire surcharge de travail vous
rendez les permanences de soins
obligatoires sur tout le territoire
national et à tous les professionnels de
santé alors que nombre d'entre eux
approchent de leur retraite que vous
risquez de précipiter manque de
reconnaissance vous réformer les CESP
pour les jeunes médecins Sans
revaloriser l'allocation manque de
moyens humains vous allez accorder un
titre de séjour à des extras
même redonner envie à nos compatriotes
d'exercer dans leur propre pays la PPL
ne répondant pas aux attentes les
différents groupes ont déposé de
nombreux amendements je vous remercie
merci Monsieur frapper madame matilinier
pour la France insoumise s'il vous plaît
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur chers collègues trouver un
médecin pouvoir aide-soigné correctement
à une distance raisonnable de son
domicile voilà la première préoccupation
des Françaises et Français aujourd'hui
depuis 10 ans nous avons perdu 7000
généralistes libéraux 6 millions de
Français non pas de médecins traitant
plus de 8 millions de Français habitent
dans un désert médical il est plus que
temps de prendre à bras le corps les
problématiques d'accès aux soins c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui a entrepris le groupe
de travail transpartisan initié par
Guillaume Garraud des députés allant des
républicains à la nupesse travaillent
ensemble depuis presque un an et ont il
a élaboré une proposition de loi pour
lutter contre les déserts médicaux nous
regrettons donc que le choix de ne pas
inscrire cette proposition à l'ordre du
jour alors qu'elle recueille plus de 200
signatures de députés de tout bord et
que la pétition demandant son
inscription à l'ordre du jour à atteint
des dizaines de milliers de signataires
cependant nous profiterons de ce texte
pour mettre au débat les mesures qui
sont présentées dans la proposition de
loi transpartisanes concernant le texte
de Monsieur Valtou que nous examinons
aujourd'hui la réorganisation
territoriale en matière de santé
répondra peu à l'urgence que traverse
notre nos territoires aujourd'hui par
exemple vous proposez que ce soit au
Conseil territoriaux de santé de définir
les objectifs prioritaires d'accès aux
soins et d'appliquer le plan territorial
de santé pourquoi pas mais avec quel
médecin et comment assurer l'égalité
d'accès aux soins sur l'ensemble du
territoire si la gouvernance est utile
uniquement à l'échelon locale
cette organisation territoriale ne peut
fonctionner que si elle est accompagnée
de mesures fortes afin de fléchir
l'installation des professionnels de
santé dans l'objectif de mieux les
répartir sur l'ensemble du territoire
aujourd'hui faute de remplaçant 12000
médecins exercent encore alors qu'ils
ont dépassé l'âge de la de la retraite
certes vous rêvez de faire travailler
les gens jusqu'à 80 ans mais ce n'est
pas notre cas
je proteste aussi vivement vis-à-vis du
caractère ircevable de nos amendements
ouvrant droit au contrat d'engagement de
service public dès la première année sur
critères sociaux ou territoriaux en
l'état notre position sur ce texte
dépendra donc largement de l'adoption de
certains nombres d'amendements qui
permettront de l'enrichir je vous
remercie merci madame millilier je donne
la parole à Monsieur Colombani pour
liberté indépendant outre-mer et
territoires merci merci Madame
présidente mais si le rapporteur chers
collègues la PPL de notre collègue
Frédéric Valtou que nous examinons
aujourd'hui a pour objectif d'améliorer
l'accès aux soins j'ai l'impression que
cet objectif est devenu une sorte de
mantra que nous répétons régulièrement
puisque nous assistons dans cette
commission un véritable défilé de texte
qui s'en saisissent
il me semble qu'un manquablement les
propositions qu'il contiennent suscitent
la circonscription la circonspection des
concitoyens et un profond en
mécontentement de la part des
professionnels de santé il faut dire que
tous constatent une véritable
impuissance de la part des pouvoirs
publics face aux délitement de l'offre
de soins le déficit d'accès aux soins se
fait de plus en plus prégnant et la
désertification médicale gagne chaque
jour du terrain je tiens vous alerter
sur la lassitude et la souffrance des
acteurs de la médecine libérale elle
porte un regard inquiet et méfiant
envers ce texte elle estime que nous
allons lui porter un nouveau coup de
grâce administratif en ajoutant des
lourdeurs un secteur qui coule déjà sur
des procédures l'article premier est
symptomatique d'un faculté à créer des
usines à gaz qui s'accumulent qui
accumulent des échelons administratives
dans nos comprenons pas bien à quoi il
pourrait servir c'est précisément
l'inverse dont nous avons besoin de la
simplification administrative pour
dégager du temps médical disponible
de même il n'est pas raisonnable de
faire peser sur les épaules de la
médecine de vie la responsabilité
politique du manque de moyens alloué à
des hôpitaux-angles de la fermeture de
lit de service d'urgence ou de maternité
les mêmes causes produisent les mêmes
effets les mêmes mots de l'hôpital et de
la médecine des villes sont des vases
communicants je reviendrai plus en
détail sur les dispositions que contient
ce texte à travers la défense de mes
amendements il me semble
urgent de changer de prise nous devons
cesser de penser que nous pouvons guérir
un mal aussi profond en posant des
pansements sur les jambes de bois je
vous remercie
merci Monsieur Colombani Monsieur
Philippe Vigier pour démocrate modèle et
indépendant merci
merci madame la Présidente sur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues
notre collègue du rassemblement national
que sur ce sujet il n'y a pas matière à
renoncement et j'ai entendu de
renoncement et pas de proposition dans
votre message je veux dire avec beaucoup
d'humilité ici que ça fait quelques
années que je suis cette question
terrible où j'ai vu toutes les majorités
les unes après les autres se fracturer
parce qu'il n'était incapable de faire
en sorte que l'on puisse avancer s'il y
a eu deux avancées le numéro s'aperçu il
n'a pas été supprimé j'en fasse faire
ressources numérise apertus on l'a
augmenté et la deuxième décision c'est
la création comme vous le savez les CTPS
qui quand même a été un élément
fédérateur très important donc un vrai
travail a été accompli dans un groupe
transpartisan dont j'ai fait partie et
je dis à Frédéric Van tout qu'il a
également de son côté fait un gros
travail et je pense qu'il y a
l'intelligence collective qui est devant
nous soit on est capable les uns et les
autres
de faire en sorte d'aboutir sur un texte
solide qui permettra d'apporter à cet
homme de piste et d'ailleurs vous
observerez sur le rapporteur qu'il n'y a
pas un seul amendement nous ayons déposé
pour détricoter des mesures vous avez
prises et que vous proposez donc des
mesures complémentaires ou des mesures
différentes parce que ce sujet ne
supporte pas mais semble-t-il que l'on
puisse envoyer à la figure des choses
dont on sait très bien que elles sont
totalement réalisables mais alors ma
surprise la présidence c'est de voir que
tu dis de l'article 40 beaucoup
d'amendements
avaient très passé quand je vois que le
contrat d'engagement de service public
met en place dans cette maison en 2015
on veut l'élargir et là on nous le
supprime
franchement il faudra nous donner des
explications quand je vois qu'il y a des
expérimentations proposées et sur
lesquels on dit encore l'article 45
s'applique quel dommage sur une telle
question il me semble qu'il y a quelques
jours d'autres textes plus lourds ont pu
passer avec des fourches claudines un
peu plus élargies j'invite chacun à
réfléchir à tout cela
merci Monsieur Vigier monsieur Guillaume
Garreau pour socialiste et apparentés
merci
la désertification médicale ça a été dit
c'est 6 millions de Français qui vivent
dans un territoire où on peine à trouver
un médecin et donc qui n'ont pas de
médecin traitant
et c'est du coup un enjeu politique
majeur parce que c'est vécu comme une
insécurité sociale
dans le pays qui
a fait de la sécurité sociale un des
fondements de son vivre ensemble
c'est aussi un enjeu républicain parce
que la désertification médicale s'est
vécue comme un sentiment d'abandon par
la République qui échoue à garantir
cette formidable promesse d'égalité qui
était celle de 1945 dans l'accès aux
soins et dans l'accès à la santé alors
ça a été dit aussi moi j'avais pris
l'initiative en juillet dernier bon ça
fera bientôt un an de constituer un
groupe de travail transpartisan sur
cette question avec des députés de
gauche de droite du Centre
avec ce souci comme la dit Philippe
vivier très justement de réussir à
trouver des solutions qui puissent nous
rassembler dans une intelligence
collective alors nous avons rédigé
ensemble une proposition de loi
transpartisane qui rassemble aujourd'hui
205 députés
issus de toutes les sensibilités
républicaines de l'Assemblée nous avons
demandé à plusieurs reprises que cette
ex puisse être inscrit au débat
nous n'avons pas été entendu donc nous
profitons de
du texte que dépose aujourd'hui Frédéric
valtoux pour essayer de l'enrichir et
moi je veux remercier Frédéric Valtou du
dialogue de qualité qu'il a ouvert avec
nous je le dis d'emblée je serai rapide
pour terminer
en commission nous ne présenterons pas
de
d'amendement sur la régulation
proprement dit nous réservons ce débat
que nous avons déjà ici même eu ensemble
à la séance publique mais nous
essaierons sur d'autres aspects
fondamentaux de pouvoir aussi améliorer
les choses et nous souhaitons un débat
sans dogmatisme avec la avec le souci de
rechercher des solutions
je vous remercie je vous remercie
monsieur garrot monsieur Paul Christophe
pour horizon et à parenté merci merci
le rapporteur mes chers collègues notre
pays connaît depuis plusieurs décennies
une distorsion au sein du système de
santé c'était fait six eaux entre
l'offre de soins et la demande trouve sa
source dans la pénurie de médecin que
nous traversons elle-même conjugué à une
augmentation de la population et à son
vieillissement face à ce constat criant
il y a une situation qui ne cesse de
s'aggraver la majorité et son
gouvernement ont supprimé dès 2019 le
numerus clausus est proposé la mise en
place de nombreux dispositifs au travers
la réforme ma santé 2022 à titre
d'exemple cela c'est notamment traduit
par le déploiement de 1000 communautés
professionnels territoriales de santé
les CPTs ou encore voir la création de
l'aide à l'embauche d'assistant médicaux
dans les cabinets libéraux dans
l'objectif de promouvoir un égal accès
aux soins pour tous les solutions
nationales précédemment citées doivent
être complétés par des initiatives
locales afin que les réponses apportées
correspondent aux besoins de chaque
territoire par cette présente
proposition de loi portée par notre
collègue revivalto et notre groupe
horizon nous souhaitons que les
soignants en ville ou à l'hôpital
puissent se coordonner entre eux pour
trouver des solutions adaptées à leurs
enjeux d'organisation des soins locaux
en renforçant les missions du conseil
territorial de santé le CTS en
rattachant chaque professionnelle de
santé aux communautés professionnelles
territoriales en rendant effective la
participation de tous à la permanence de
soins en interdisant l'intérim aux
professionnels médicaux et par médicaux
en début de carrière cette proposition
de loi participe ainsi au chantier
entamé depuis 2017 par la refonte notre
système de santé elle garde comme
ambition une amélioration de l'accès aux
soins des Français en tenant compte des
changements d'aspiration des
professionnels de santé en complément le
groupe horizon et apparenté portera cinq
amendements partagent les objectifs de
cette proposition de loi est visant
notamment à l'ouverture de la mise à
disposition de fonctionnaires
territoriaux aux maisons de santé
cabinet libéraux en zone soudance la
définition du médecin coordinateur
d'epad comme médecin traitant du
résident et des amendements pour lutter
contre le nomadisme médical nous
proposons ainsi les solutions concrètes
pour un renforcement durable notre
système de santé devenu comme le rappel
très justement notre rapporteur la
première préoccupation des Français
comme un écho aussi millions de nos
citoyens en absence de médecins traitant
merci Monsieur Christophe la parole est
à Monsieur Sébastien paye ta vie
écologiste merci
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues le texte
que nous étudions aujourd'hui ambitionne
de faire du territoire de santé
l'échelon privilégié du
pilotage des politiques de santé et
d'accès aux soins en ce sens nous
considérons qu'il va dans la bonne
direction il tend vers une gouvernance
construite sur une logique
populationnelle où l'offre est
déterminée en fonction des besoins en
santé du territoire mais le groupe
écologiste fait toutefois part de son
étonnement alors que cette proposition
de loi abandonne en cours de route
d'autres pistes pour améliorer l'offre
de soins ces pistes avaient été avancées
dans la première proposition de loi dont
Monsieur Valtou était déjà rapporteur
alors nous nous interrogeons monsieur le
rapporteur que s'est-il passé que
s'est-il passé pour cette proposition de
loi ne reprenne ni la levée du parcours
de soins coordonnées pour les patients
sans médecins généralistes ni la
régulation à l'installation des médecins
via la RS
quoi qu'il en soit nous devons être
lucide la démographie médicale sera en
berne pour quelques années encore ainsi
ni la première proposition de loi ni
l'actuelle ne permettront de répondre à
la problématique de l'accès aux soins la
pénurie inédite de médecin que nous
subissons et le résultat de 30 ans de
manquement de l'État à ses obligations
en matière d'accès égale aux soins que
ce soit par une régulation du numerus
clausus incapable d'anticiper les
besoins ou par un nom d'âme 2023 qui ne
dépasse même pas l'inflation ma
circonscription la Dordogne une
n'échappe pas à cette abandon comme de
nombreux territoires en France alors que
les accueils de nos quatre centres
hospitaliers sont forcés d'être régulier
par le 15 fautes de personnels
disponibles ou alors que la maternité de
Sarlat est en danger puisque nous allons
inexorablement manqué de médecin
jusqu'en 2030 quelles réponses apporter
au 8 millions de Françaises et Français
privés de soins si le texte est porteur
de quelques avancées le groupe
écologiste fera plusieurs propositions
pour une gouvernance qui remette les
besoins et l'accès digne aux soins au
cœur de ses priorités nous appellerons
ainsi à faire de l'espérance de vie en
bonne santé un objectif de la politique
de santé de la nation à expérimenter un
dispositif de contractualisation plus
réelle entre les acteurs de la santé
autour de certains objectifs
prioritaires ou à lancer une loi de
programmation plus annuelle pour la
santé
merci Monsieur Payet ta vie Monsieur
Pierre d'arrivy Le Gauche démocrate et
républicaine merci
madame la Présidente
d'abord je dois dire que je suis ravi
d'être ici avec vous pour délibérer sur
cette proposition de loi sur un sujet
important une proposition de loi dont je
me réjouis qu'elle est passée l'article
40 et je me réjouis aussi d'être ici
avec vous pour examiner un certain
nombre d'amendements je le dis comme ça
pas toujours été si facile que ça dans
la période c'est bien que nous puissions
nous réunir ici en commission dans ces
conditions sur une proposition de loi et
c'est donc sur une initiative
parlementaire
tout à l'heure il a été signalé qu'un
certain nombre d'amendement avait été
écarté moi aussi cher Philippe Vigier je
le regrette et je le regrette d'autant
plus que comme nous avons eu un débat
relativement restreint sur le PLFSS
c'était aussi une occasion de pouvoir
discuter d'un certain nombre d'enjeux
auxquels nous devons faire face je dois
dire que je m'interroge un peu sur la
manière dont le gouvernement lui-même a
annoncé qu'il allait s'emparer de cette
proposition de loi en en faisant un de
ces véhicules et je pense que cette
méthode est très problématique parce que
de ce fait il s'aggère d'un certain
nombre de ses obligations lorsque il
dépose un projet de loi donc nous
verrons ce qu'il en est
je dois dire que cela étant sur le fond
je reste un peu circonspect devant la
proposition que vous nous proposez et
assez dubitatif sur sa capacité en
réalité à faire face aux enjeux
considérables d'accès aux soins auxquels
nous faisons face dans notre pays vous
pointez la responsabilité collective des
acteurs locaux et nous sommes pour nous
le développement de la démocratie
sanitaire mais au passage c'est un mot
vous faites disparaître je sais pas bien
pourquoi dans votre proposition de loi
et en réalité vous ne pointez pas
l'autre versant c'est la responsabilité
de la puissance publique de l'État qui
est responsable lui de l'accès aux soins
et du droit à la santé et donc je pense
que du coup ça crée quand même un petit
hiatus je reviendrai sans doute dans le
débat sur un certain nombre d'enjeux
nous avons nous-mêmes déposé un certain
nombre d'amendements avec Guillaume gar
Raud ou d'autres et je pointe la
question par exemple du développement
des centres de santé mais nous aurons
l'occasion d'y revenir
merci beaucoup monsieur d'arrivyle je
vais donner la parole à au rapporteur
monsieur Valteau merci
merci merci à tous de ces interventions
nourries et qui nous permettent déjà de
rentrer dans le dans le débat je vais
essayer de compléter de répondre plutôt
à certains interrogations qui ont été
évoqués par les uns et les autres je
pense qu'il y a un contexte
effectivement dans lequel nous
intervenons et Jean-François Roussel a
rappelé nous sommes pas un moment anodin
dans l'histoire de notre système de
santé il y a des tensions multiples qui
sont des tensions démographiques ça a
été dit aussi par Monsieur frapper il y
a des tensions qui sont des tensions
budgétaires il y a des tensions irritées
de système qui n'ont pas su évoluer on
l'a dit ces 20 dernières années et dont
il s'agit pas ici parce que ce serait du
temps perdu de chercher la
responsabilité des uns et des autres on
a collectivement à devoir arriver à
répondre à cette question qui est une
question concrète de nos concitoyens
comment accéder à un médecin comment
être suivi dans son parcours de soins et
on a j'allais dire je pense tous en tête
finalement à devoir d'humilité aussi
parce que s'il y avait une baguette
magique s'il y avait surtout une réponse
magique
évidemment qu'on serait heureux les uns
les autres de pouvoir la porter mais il
y en a pas à problème complexe réponse
qui sont multiples et dont on va espérer
collectivement et c'est l'objet du débat
qu'on va voir pendant plusieurs jours de
pouvoir effectivement à l'arrivée et de
satisfait non pas d'avoir transformé
radicalement notre système de santé au
moins d'en avoir fait bouger bouger les
lignes alors pour répondre à Monsieur
frapper qui voit
dire le le
un objet administratif se déployait à
l'infini non justement non à partir du
moment où on veut essayer de dire que le
temps est venu de faire confiance aux
acteurs de terrain il faut bien qu'à un
endroit assez acteurs de terrain se
parlent or la difficulté aujourd'hui
c'est que vous l'êtes vous comme élu
d'un territoire vous devez savoir que
finalement c'est aussi par le manque de
lieux où s'élabore collectivement des
stratégies de soins de santé c'est par
l'absence de lieu comme cela
effectivement que que qu'aujourd'hui on
a du mal à voir émerger des stratégies
conditions collective et donc pour que
les acteurs se parlent la proposition
est de s'appuyer sur le le conseil
territorial de santé qui est une
instance qui existe déjà simplement lui
donner au contraire du sens du muscle de
la force et que cette gouvernance
collective puisse effectivement prendre
corps donc on invente rien on n'invente
pas des échelons de plus on s'appuie
simplement sur quelque chose qui existe
dans les textes qui existent peu sur le
terrain pour en faire au contraire un
endroit où soignant collectivité locale
décideurs publics de l'État organisme de
la de la sécurité sociale pourront faire
converger des points de vue se doter de
priorité et ensuite les mettre en oeuvre
c'est-à-dire enfin arriver à essayer de
décloisonner notre système de santé donc
là dessus je pense que au contraire ça
n'est pas un objet administratif
supplémentaire sur le dos des médecins
mais c'est simplement organiser un
moment les lieux de coopération
sur les sur les l'intervention de Madame
ignié là aussi vous avez eu raison de
rappeler la démarche la redit et
d'autres orateurs l'ont redis la
démarche transpartisanes c'est utile que
effectivement que la réflexion
collective est plus mûrir à travers
l'initiative qui a été prise par
Guillaume Garraud et d'autres depuis
plusieurs mois et quelque part tant
mieux si on arrive à faire converger les
points de vue vers des solutions qui
permettront globalement d'apporter notre
modeste pierre mais notre pierre quand
même à l'amélioration des sujets de de
santé et en tout cas merci pour je veux
dire le regard a priori ouvert que vous
avez sur la la manière dont on se
déroulait les bas qui déterminera
ensuite votre votre position monsieur
Colombani vous avez beaucoup parlé de la
médecine de ville
mais la médecine de ville n'est pas
toute la médecine et les acteurs
libéraux ne sont pas tout le système de
santé à eux tout seul j'ai beaucoup de
respect pour la médecine libérale et je
pense que la force de notre système de
santé c'est justement d'avoir deux
jambes une médecine publique et de
médecine libérale et la force de notre
système de santé c'est d'avoir sur le
terrain
des milliers milliers dizaines de
milliers de médecins généralistes ont
souvent été décriés par leurs propres
professions eux-mêmes d'ailleurs dans
leur qualité dans leur rôle et d'avoir
des milliers de médecins généralistes
qui j'allais dire tiennent le terrain et
sont véritablement avec les paramédicaux
avec tous ceux qui les accompagnent mais
où les entourent mais sont vraiment au
chevet de nos de nos concitoyens mais
néanmoins il n'y a pas que la médecine
libérale et donc il faut essayer de
juger aussi l'intérêt et l'approche de
ce texte en ayant une approche qui soit
globale et peut-être se sortir un peu de
cette manière dont présente certains
acteurs professionnels comme si la
médecine libérale était l'alpha et
l'oméga de notre système de santé non il
y a différents acteurs et cette
pluralité d'acteurs qui nous revient
d'essayer de faire coordonner et avancer
avancer ensemble je réponds la même
manière aussi à Pierre dareville il
s'agit pas de faire porter sur les
acteurs de terrain la responsabilité des
politiques de l'État il s'agit pas
d'exonérer l'état de ces de sa nécessité
d'avoir une stratégie des ambitions et
et et
qui soit national il s'agit simplement
de demander aux acteurs de terrain
d'organiser la déclinaison territoriale
et moi je pense que le temps est venu
justement de sortir d'un système qui est
éminemment jacobin éminemment parisien
éminemment vu depuis le prisme de Paris
en tout cas qui a souffert de ça pendant
des années pour enfin essayer de donner
des marges de manœuvre et d'adaptation
aux acteurs de terrain eux savent mieux
que nous mieux que quiconque et mieux
que sans doute les bureaux du ministère
de la Santé quand bien même les bureaux
de ministère de la santé sont tout à
fait respectables comment on doit
organiser dans les différents coins de
notre grand et beau pays la réponse à la
demande de soins et à la demande de
prise en charge des Français et donc il
s'agit pas dans de reporter sur la
responsabilité il s'agit de de leur
demander comment il décline localement
les objectifs et les stratégies les
stratégies nationales voilà merci à
Philippe Vigier de ces mots et de
rappeler que l'intelligence collective
nous permettra sans doute d'avancer Paul
Christophe a repris j'allais dire la
même la même la même espoir que de notre
discussion permet effectivement de faire
émerger des solutions qui soient
porteuses de sens à la fois pour les
professionnels de santé mais finalement
pour les Français parce que on est là
pour les Français et pas uniquement pour
le les professionnels de santé même s'il
faut tenir compte de et effectivement je
reprends ce que disait notamment
Jean-François Rousset il faut que dans
cette affaire et ça me permettra de
parler éventuellement de la liberté
d'installation et du débat qu'on va
avoir en séance mais il faut dans cette
affaire nous emmenons les professionnels
de santé c'est ma conviction aujourd'hui
notre système de santé le principal de
ces difficultés le principal de ces mots
c'est le problème de la pyramide
démographique si on n'a pas assez de
professionnels de santé pour s'occuper
et pour répondre aux besoins de santé et
on sait monsieur pedavyl a très
justement rappelé que dans les années
qui viennent on n'aura pas plus de
professionnels de santé et au contraire
on a encore des années de tension
extrême auxquelles il va falloir qu'on
fasse face et donc mieux faire
travailler les uns et les autres offrir
des éléments de souplesse aux uns et aux
autres pour inventer des prises en
charge différents tout effectivement
nous permettra de répondre concrètement
à cette question mais néanmoins il faut
pas que nous ne serions dans un attitude
où on s'oppose par principe et et aux
professionnels de santé parce que s'il
décide de poser l'organisme
effectivement on fera de belles lois
mais concrètement pendant le concitoyens
ça leur a pas servi à grand chose c'est
pour ça c'est pour ça et je réponds à
Monsieur pedavy de la même manière qui
me disait par rapport au texte initial
de thomasnier il y a des petites
différences mais oui il y a des petites
différences parce qu'effectivement ma
conviction à moi c'est que dans une
période de pénurie de soignants
imaginez par la contrainte et faire
croire aux Français que par un système
d'installation régulier nous pourrons
mieux organiser le système
quelque part c'est une fausse solution
qu'à terme lorsque effectivement il y
aura plus de soignants qui arriveront
dans la carrière plus de médecins formés
qui commenceront leur leur exercice
veillez à ce que un système permet de
pas reproduire les erreurs du passé de
concentration des professionnels de
soins sur certains territoires au
détriment d'autres là je pense que ce
sera utile mais dans une période de
pénurie comme celle que nous allons
encore connaître pendant 5 à 10 ans
toute volonté de mieux répartir les
choses n'amèneront pas ne rendront qu'un
territoire plus riche en médecin en tout
cas c'est ma conviction mais on est là
bien sûr pour pour échanger sur ce sur
ce sujet voilà je pense avoir répondu à
l'essentiel des interrogations portées
par par les uns et par les autres
merci beaucoup
merci Monsieur valetot donc nous allons
commencer à l'examen du texte à
l'article premier donc par des par des
amendements de suppression de l'article
donc je vais donner la parole à Monsieur
frapper
pour l'amendement 105 s'il vous plaît
monsieur frapper
merci madame la Présidente l'amendement
105 vise à demander la suppression de
l'article effectivement le CTS à mon
avis et un autre avis va lourdir le
travail administratif des professionnels
de santé et plus particulièrement des
médecins libéraux nouvelle organes qui
vient s'ajouter des gens en CPTs aux ESP
existants qui n'apportent pas de
solution qui permettent de faire face à
la désertification médicale on pourrait
s'interroger sur la réelle utilité
d'interlastique qui vient donner la
responsabilité aux professionnels de
santé sur le territoire et de la
régularité de la régulation pardon sur
un territoire prédéfini de l'offre de
santé ce qui ne répond pas aux missions
ni aux besoins des professionnels qui
sont déjà en surcharge de travail je
vous remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur alors bien
sûr je serais contre la suppression de
cet article parce que j'allais dire
c'est un des moteurs de cette de ce
texte je le redis le conseil territorial
de santé n'est pas un organe
supplémentaire le conseil de territorial
de santé aujourd'hui existe et parfois
soyons honnêtes ils ne sert pas à grand
chose donc l'objectif c'est
effectivement d'organiser un lieu où on
puisse où les acteurs les parties
prenantes de la prise en charge des
Français puissent partager ensemble des
stratégies
les libéraux doivent parler avec les
Hospitaliers les soignants doivent
parler avec les collectivités locales
l'administration doit écouter les
professionnels de terrain qui soit
public ou privés les associations de
patients doivent avoir leur voix au
chapitre et doivent pouvoir évoquer
aussi ce qu'ils portent en légitimité de
leur point de vue voilà donc il y a moi
je c'est difficile de poursuivre
l'objectif de meilleure coordination des
uns et des autres décloisonnement du
système adaptation du système de santé
aux besoins du territoire si on ne crée
aucun lieu où les uns les autres
discutent moi je crois pas que de
manière spontanée et invisible les
choses puissent dessiner si personne ne
se parle de manière institutionnelle il
s'agit pas de faire un de devoir un
organe qui qui soit une coquille vie au
contraire et c'est le sens de l'article
1 il y a des des compétences très
précises sur la permanence des soins sur
la juste répartition des forces
médicales dans un territoire qui
permettront effectivement de de trouver
peut-être collectivement des solutions
c'est pour ça il faut bien organiser je
veux dire le dialogue entre tous donc je
suis contre la suppression de cet
article 1 qui viderait de sens tout ce
travail
oui monsieur Vigier
oui parce que si vous supprimez
l'article 1 vous allez m'expliquer
comment vous allez proposer à des
professionnels de santé de s'organiser
pour améliorer l'offre de soins pour
nous concitoyens dans les territoires ça
n'existe pas la violence des soins c'est
une erreur stratégique grave qui a été
faite il y a plus de 20 ans d'ailleurs
tout à l'heure dans les débat préalable
vous savez c'est en 1998 on a fait mieux
dans ce pays on a encouragé les médecins
à partir à la retraite qu'on appelle le
Mika c'est madame Aubry qui portait tout
ça donc de grâce il nous disent quoi les
professionnels on veut se retrouver
autour d'une table on veut voir comment
s'organise avec les collectivités avec
l'assurance maladie mais laissons les
s'organiser la preuve de CPT sont un
succès si vous supprimez l'article 1
vous videz de sa substance toute action
je regrette malheureusement qu'une fois
de plus vous soyez dans la destruction
mais pas dans la proposition
merci nous allons procéder donc au vote
monsieur Rousset je vous avais pas vu
oui moi je trouve dommage de supprimer
un article qui permet de faire vivre une
structure qui existe déjà et qui est un
lieu de dialogue et et d'avancer voilà
donc je conforte la vie de Frédéric
Valtou
merci donc là nous allons procéder au
vote de l'amendement donc de Monsieur
frapper qui est pour
qui est contre
il est rejeté merci
nous allons commencer par des
amendements pour être mis en discussion
commune je donne la parole à Madame
minier
pour l'amendement 593
oui par cet amendement nous souhaitons
que le que la gouvernance des
territoires de santé par les Conseils
territoriaux de santé soit une
expérimentation
cette dispositif de disposition changent
de manière significative le
fonctionnement territorial de la
politique d'offre de soins et pourtant
nous ne disposons d'aucune étude
d'impact pour en évaluer les
conséquences nous pensons donc qu'il est
nécessaire qu'une expérimentation ait
lieu avant que le changement de
gouvernance soit appliqué à l'ensemble
de territoires et en plus nous proposons
que l'intervention de l'ARS est lieu en
référence au plan régional de santé qui
reste la feuille de route pour répondre
aux besoins définis par le diagnostic
territorial de santé merci oui merci
Madame minier je donne la parole à
Monsieur cloué pour l'amendement 596
merci madame la Présidente un amendement
qui fait tout à fait écho la proposition
précédente puisqu'il s'agit là aussi de
convertir ce qui est proposé ici donc
d'avoir un nouvel échelon en tout cas un
nouvel espace de raisonnement sur la sur
la santé publique et d'en faire une
expérimentation dans 6 départements
durant cinq ans et ce pour deux raisons
d'abord parce que si votre proposition
vise à muscler un peu on va dire
renforcer une structure qui
déterminerait elle-même son propre
périmètre ça signifie aussi renvoyer au
second rang l'ARS et avec du coup ouvrir
un risque qui est celui de compliqué
l'effort de convergence entre
territoires donc c'est une des craintes
qu'on a et pour laquelle nous sommes que
l'expérimentation permettrait de
répondre et de crantée dans le temps
deuxièmement il y a aussi un risque de
multiplier les inégalités d'accès aux
soins selon les habitudes des
professionnels de santé d'un territoire
à l'autre parce qu'il y a des
territoires on voit très bien comment
des réseaux préexistants vont s'en
paraître cet espace pour travailler
ensemble d'autres ou ces réseaux
n'existent pas et dès lors cette disons
que cette nouvelle structure à périmètre
variable pourrait conduire à des
ruptures d'égalité devant les soins donc
ces deux motivations pour nous afin de
proposer un passage en expérimentation
préalable
oui merci Monsieur Grelier s'il vous
plaît pour votre amendement 666 il est
défendu madame la Présidente
merci excusez-moi j'avais de problème
avec les micros
nous allons donc donner la parole à
notre rapporteur pour
merci beaucoup je suis défavorable à ces
à ces amendements parce que je vois pas
le l'intérêt de passer par la le temps
de l'expérimentation je pense que on est
sur je le redis des périmètres qui
existent depuis 2016 qui n'ont pas
peut-être été actionnés de la même avec
la même vitalité selon les régions
dont il faut laisser le temps aux
acteurs effectivement de de peut-être de
réorienter les périmètres eux-mêmes mais
qui globalement aujourd'hui doivent être
maintenant doivent être le lieu la
concertation de la déclinaison des
politiques territoriales et face à un
problème urgent je ne dis pas que cette
recette de faire dialoguer les gens dans
les conseils territoriaux de santé
amènera du jour au lendemain du mieux
mais néanmoins je ne vois pas l'utilité
d'attendre et de pas se saisir de cette
de ces de ce levier de très vite aux
quatre coins du territoire pouvoir
améliorer le décloisonnement et
l'efficacité du travail en commun donc
je pense que
il n'est pas utile et nécessaire de
passer par la case expérimentations
oui je vais donner la parole à Madame
Amiot qui voulait prendre la parole
merci oui merci madame la Présidente je
voulais simplement rappeler à monsieur
le rapporteur que
si nous faisons ces demandes c'est aussi
et je le rappelle parce que nous n'avons
pas d'étude d'impact sur l'existant nous
n'avons pas de bilan sur l'existant donc
encore une fois mettre la charrue avant
les bœufs c'est
moi j'entends l'urgence et je suis la
première à travailler sur sur l'urgence
absolue effectivement de l'accès aux
soins pour autant
faire les choses dans le désordre ça
revient souvent à faire des erreurs qui
va falloir rectifier derrière et ça ira
de la confiance et ça Hérode l'accès aux
soins donc vraiment entendez cette
importance de de d'une part de faire des
études impact et de faire des bilans de
l'existant d'aller vérifier sur le
terrain ce qui ce qui fonctionne ce qui
ne fonctionne pas
merci je vais donc mettre au voile les
amendements un par un donc l'amendement
de Madame minier le 593 qui est pour
qui est contre
il est rejeté
ensuite nous avons l'amendement de
Monsieur Clouet le 586
qui est pour
merci qui est contre il est rejeté
et donc l'amendement de Monsieur Grelier
qui est pour
qui est contre
il est rejeté
donc monsieur je suis absent
monsieur d'arrivée pour le 389
oui madame la Présidente donc la notion
de territoire de santé mise en oeuvre de
la loi dans le cadre de la loi P HPST a
été supprimé par la loi de modernisation
de notre système de santé de 2016 pour
lui substituer la notion de territoire
de démocratie sanitaire et inscrire
celle de conseils territoire de santé
donc l'article le premier procède ainsi
une forme de retour en arrière
puisqu'elle substitue la notion de
territoire de démocratie sanitaire celle
de territoire de santé dont nous
interrogeons comme je l'ai indiqué tout
à l'heure sur la portée pratique de
cette substitution et ça signification
et donc considérant en revanche ça
portait symbolique pourrait ne pas être
anodine et peut sous-entendre l'échec
peut-être la fin de cette démarche de
démocratie sanitaire en tout cas telle
qu'elle est entendus dans les
dispositifs précédents ce qui mériterait
peut-être une plus ample discussion il y
a eu effectivement un certain nombre
d'écueils notion de territoire
démocratie sanitaire
signifie que les politiques
territoriales de santé doivent être
mises en place dans la concertation avec
l'ensemble des acteurs de santé sur le
rapporteur tout à l'heure vous m'avez
répondu moi je suis pour le
développement de la démocratie sanitaire
je constate qu'on a plutôt effectivement
reculé de ce point de vue avec un
certain nombre de mesures y compris dans
la gestion de l'hôpital public
d'ailleurs
donc c'est un vrai sujet de
préoccupation parce qu'il me concerne
et je m'interroge voilà sur le la
signification de cette dénomination
nouvelle
merci Monsieur d'arriver monsieur le
rapporteur
oui moi je suis comme vous monsieur
l'air avec je suis un défenseur de la
démocratie sanitaire et je suis
convaincu effectivement que c'est aussi
par ce biais là que notre système de
santé doit progresser mais néanmoins là
il s'agit il s'agit juste je vais y
arriver il s'agit juste de mettre en
cohérence je dire des dénominations
entre le territoire de santé le conseil
du territoire de santé le projet du
territoire de santé et j'ai soumis cette
j'ai soumis cette remarque que vous
m'avez faite à France à 60 et qui est
quand même voilà qui qui rassemble
l'ensemble des associations patients et
franchement ils n'y ont pas vu du tout à
mal bien au contraire le sujet n'est pas
là le sujet c'est pas c'est pas de
mettre en étendard la santé au dessus du
fronton de nos de nos de ces instances
de concertation c'est de la faire vivre
réellement et en l'occurrence en
concrétisant en donnant du poids du sens
assez conseil territoriaux de santé et
bien on fait la démocratie sanitaire
beaucoup plus que simplement en
affichant le terme démocratie sanitaire
sur des structures qui jusqu'à présent
ne le l'était pas donc voilà je suis
pour la cohérence et du coup je vous
propose de retirer votre amendement
sinon je serais contre parce que la
démocratie sanitaire est s'incarne dans
la proposition de loi que nous portons
oui monsieur cloué vous avez la parole
merci madame la Présidente du coup je
suis un petit peu étonné par par la
réponse du rapporteur puisque j'entends
que le terme ne change rien aux
pratiques donc dans ce cas là autant le
laisser c'est une bonne nouvelle ça
plaît je pense pour l'adoption de
l'amendement de mon camarade pierre et
deuxièmement vous dites la démocratie
sanitaire elle s'incarne plus qu'elle ne
se dit et bien donc une raison de plus
de la dire et de l'incarner je pense que
les deux motifs que vous donnez sont des
motifs d'adoption de cette excellente
amendement de Pierre d'arriville vous
n'avez pas entendu le motif de cohérence
que j'ai mis en avant et et de
lisibilité vous savez on aura l'occasion
d'en reparler et on le sait tous parce
que dans les territoires on vit tout ça
l'enchevêtrement des procédures des
effectivement des termes complexes
derrière plus personne très bien ne sait
ce qu'il y a
territoire de santé conseil territorial
de santé projet territorial de santé
c'est d'une extrême lisibilité cohérence
c'est mon argument principal pour
rejeter l'amendement
merci Monsieur leur apporteur je vais
mettre donc on voit l'amendement de
Monsieur d'arriville le 389 qui est pour
qui est contre
il est rejeté
nous allons passer à l'amendement
excusez-moi je suis un peu enroué nous
allons passer à la mandement de Madame
Rista
457 j'avance assez vite parce qu'il y a
des absents vous comprendrez voilà
madame la Présidente c'est un amendement
qui vise à préciser que le conseil
territorial de santé tienne compte des
territoires des groupements hospitaliers
territoriaux vous savez et on l'avait pu
l'évaluer dans cette commission
l'efficacité pendant le covid pendant la
crise sanitaire de ces groupements
hospitaliers de territoire et dans
l'idée de parajouter des couches
successives il est important de pouvoir
le mieux possible tenir compte de la
géographie de ces groupements pour
mettre en rapport les conseils
territoriaux de santé oui monsieur le
rapporteur à vous
merci madame la Présidente bon
je crois que si on veut que les acteurs
de terrain se sentent j'allais dire le
mieux possible dans des dans les
délimitations dans lesquelles ils vont
avoir à réfléchir à travailler il ne
faudrait pas que par la loi on commence
à rigidifier l'exercice de périmétrages
les groupements hospitalier territoire
ont des surfaces qui sont très
différentes je vais prendre l'exemple de
l'Île-de-France je peux prendre
l'exemple de l'ancienne région Limousin
où il y a une seule un seul groupement
hospital territoire dans dans l'ancien
Limousin à l'échelle de l'ancien
Limousin en Île-de-France on est par
dessus les frontières départementales
ailleurs on est à l'intérieur des
frontières départementales
et les groupements hospitaliers
territoires ce sont des objets publics
entre des outils à la pour les hôpitaux
je pense que si on commence à vouloir
harmoniser des périmètres qui n'ont pas
vocation forcément être harmonisés
puisque le groupement hospital
territoire c'est la stratégie publique
pour organiser dire une prise en charge
depuis la proximité jusqu'au plateau
technique les plus élaborés et que donc
à partir de là cette logique là elle
n'est pas forcément superposable avec
des territoires des bassins de vie qui
ont leur cohérence et qui allient le
privé le public et d'autres acteurs
c'est pour ça que je serai assez
favorable au retrait de cet amendement
qui je pense pas ne vient enfin qui je
pense ne vient pas améliorer la
lisibilité de la démarche
je vais le retirer à cette explication
dans le micro
dans le micro madame risque
il est important de rappeler cette
importance des groupements hospitaliers
territoire à mon avis et de pas su
rajouter des couches les unes aux autres
après j'entends vos arguments et les
territoires sont différents et je retire
cet amendement
merci Madame Marie monsieur
oui il est rejeté non
retirer excusez-moi
non je voulais juste dire un mot de la
présidente mais
il faut éviter de sur des rigidités puis
comme le sait très bien Stéphanie risque
de l'établissement public et que si on
veut réussir un jour il faudra
complètement décloisonné tout ce qui se
passe entre le public et le privé et
ensuite j'ajoute que pour être par
exemple à l'extrémité d'un territoire
dans lequel j'ai acheté une partie de ce
territoire et travaille avec un autre
département donc les contraintes qui
pourraient y avoir si je la mets il y
avait un cadre trop strict qui était
donné au travers notamment il a été
retiré pour le moment donc on en
reparlera peut-être pour la séance merci
au moment de l'article 6 d'ailleurs je
suis en désaccord avec la proposition
que vous faites mais je suis pas sûr que
les ght tels qui sont bâtis puissent
constituer le statut en la structure et
vous l'avez dit de l'organisation
territoriale de santé d'autant plus
qu'il y a une extrême diversité de ces
j'ai acheté dans leur taille dans y
compris l'activité qui peut être la leur
parfois et je nous invite à regarder le
rapport qui a été produit il y a pas si
longtemps avec
mon collègue de laine
marque de latte qui faisait un état des
lieux de ces j'ai acheté au nom de la
Mecque je pense ça devrait nous
interroger sur
l'état actuel des choses
vous voulez rajouter quelque chose c'est
le rapporteur alors je suis totalement
d'accord avec l'intervention monsieur la
Réville j'ai lu ce rapport et
effectivement il fait partie des
démonstrations des nombreuses
démonstrations qui qui expliquent il
faut être assez prudent sur
le périmètres de j'ai acheté et vouloir
tout calquer de dessus
donc nous avons passé maintenant aux
amendements pour être mis en discussion
commune monsieur frappé pour le sang
numéro 100
merci Madame pardon la présidente
l'amendement que je propose vise à
imposer une fréquence dans le l'analyse
des délimitations du territoire
aujourd'hui nous avons des analyses qui
sont faites à trois ans si l'on ajoute
la nécovie dont on analyse qui date de
2019 et l'analyse récente a été d'avril
2022 il semble nécessaire de les
réaliser plus fréquemment de manière à
permettre au cts d'anticiper l'offre de
soins au plus près du territoire
considéré l'idée est d'apporter des
réponses de manière rapide et efficace
aux demandes du territoire en analysant
de façon régulière les divers besoins
lors de manière annuelle
merci vous voulez défendre aussi le
suivant comme ça monsieur le rapporteur
pourra vous répondre ou l'avait défendu
le suivant le 101
en fait le deuxième amendement est un
amendement de repli qui vise
effectivement apporter une fréquence
mais cette fois-ci à deux ans et non pas
de manière annuelle
oui monsieur rapporteur vous présenter
votre amendement vous donnerez la vie
sur les deux précédents merci
oui je donne la vie sur les deux
précédents d'abord alors je donne donc
mon amendement effectivement était un
amendement rédactionnel qui vise à
préciser que ce sont les membres
siégeant au sein des conseils
territoriaux compétents qui pourront
redéfinir les limites des territoires de
santé en lien avec avec la RS est un
amendement rédactionnel sur les
amendements précédents et notamment
l'amendement numéro 100 je crois que il
est pas utile de rigidifier à ce
point-là le fonctionnement des
territoires de santé on le sait tous les
stratégies de mise en oeuvre de priorité
en matière de santé sont les stratégies
de longue durée de long terme et donc
vouloir introduire une sorte
d'instabilité annuelle à revoir des
périmètres ou légitimité à avoir des
périmètres alors que c'est des
stratégies long terme qui doivent
emmener des centaines et des milliers
parfois de professionnels dans des
territoires évidemment c'est assez
contradictoire il faut laisser du temps
au temps et surtout du temps
professionnel c'est d'ailleurs ce que
vous plaitiez qu'on impose pas trop ou
le moins possible aux professionnels là
en l'occurrence revoir les périmés
chaque année c'est dangereux
donc je suis contre ces amendements et
je suis bien sûr favorable au mien qui
est excellent
merci donc je vais mettre aux voix
l'amendement de Monsieur frapper numéro
100 qui est pour qui est contre
il est rejeté merci l'amendement sans de
Monsieur frapper également qui est pour
qui est contre il est rejeté
l'amendement du rapporteur monsieur
valleout
748 qui est pour
qui est contre
il est adopté et il fait tomber pour
votre information
les amendements
l'amendement numéro 1 à partir de
l'amendement du homerang de Monsieur
Garraud
jusqu'au jusqu'à l'amendement 103 de
Monsieur frapper voilà on va reprendre
donc
pas avec l'amendement de Monsieur Juvin
il n'est pas là on va reprendre avec
l'amendement de Monsieur Valtou
le 749
donc
c'est amendement vise à consolider la
rédaction de l'article premier en y
intégrant les dispositions de l'article
relatives à la composition des conseils
territoriaux de santé je défendrai un
peu plus tard un amendement de
suppression d'ailleurs de cet article 2
on cohérence avec l'amendement
749 je précise également que c'est
amendement par cet amendement qu'un
représentant des comités de massifs
concernés par les zonages par les zones
de montagne pourra également être
intégrée au cts comme c'est le cas
actuellement il y avait de ma part à
nourrir rédactionnel dans la proposition
de loi et donc je répare cet oublier
réactionnel en réintégrant
ce qui existe déjà c'est à dire là où
c'est nécessaire la présence d'un
représentant des comités de massif
merci Monsieur valtour monsieur le
rapporteur le sous amendement de
Monsieur Rousset s'il vous plaît numéro
que cette part de cet amendement vise
donc à associer les représentants des
guichets uniques départementaux à la
démarche de concertation relative à
l'organisation territoriale de santé
dont la gouvernance est assurée par le
Conseil territorial de santé l'objectif
est de prendre en compte des dispositifs
d'aide à l'installation dans la
définition de l'équilibre territorial de
l'offre de soins
merci alors le sous amendement de
Monsieur paye ta vie
765 merci
donc l'idée de pouvoir rajouter après
donc le mot santé donc les représentants
des associations de permanence des soins
de représentants du service d'accès aux
soins et de représentants les équipes de
soins spécialisés merci
la vie du rapporteur monsieur valetout
il y a un troisième amendement donc
celui de Madame Hugues qui est
cosignateur Madame mugella je la vois
pas non monsieur Rousset aller
les procédés
contribuent à l'accompagnement de
celle-ci permettent aussi à
l'amélioration de leur qualité de vie
apporte une vie régulière il s'agit
principalement d'un soutien moral ou
d'une aide à la vie quotidienne ils sont
présents au quotidien aux côtés des
personnes en perte d'autonomie et sont
donc les premiers à avoir connaissance
de l'évolution de l'état de santé leur
présence au sein des conseils
territoriaux de santé et dès lors plus
que nécessaire pour leur permettre de
participer à l'organisation du parcours
de soins et voilà
merci Monsieur rousse et monsieur le
rapporteur oui madame la Présidente je
voudrais dire aux trois ou trois
collègues qui viennent de présenter ces
trois amendements qu'il me semble
satisfait par la rédaction actuelle du
texte puisqu'effectivement sans qu'on
rentre dans une liste trop précise
l'ensemble du champ des partis prenantes
du système de santé ou la prise en
charge des Français sont mentionnées
dans l'article dans l'article initial et
donc il me semble pas
utile de préciser pour tel ou tel à
partir du moment où on reste
suffisamment large on a repris la
rédaction actuelle qui satisfait
globalement à tout le monde on invente
rien on veut juste faire fonctionner
quelque chose qui aujourd'hui ne
fonctionne pas dans les faits mais je
veux dire dans la composition et
notamment les aidants sont représentés
par les associations d'usagers donc il
me semble pas
utile d'aller jusque là donc je vous
propose de retirer vos trois amendements
merci alors les auteurs des susanements
des sous amendements que faites-vous
monsieur Petavy
vous le maintenez monsieur Rousset pour
les deux vous voulez maintenez
merci donc on va procéder au vote pour
les sous amendements je commence par
l'amendement 762 de Monsieur Rousset qui
est pour
qui est contre il est adopté
l'amendement de Monsieur Petavy le
numéro 765 qui est pour
qui est contre
il est adopté
l'amendement que Monsieur
l'amendement le deuxième amendement que
Monsieur Rousset à présenter le 761 qui
est pour
qui est contre il est adopté également
et maintenant nous en venons à
l'amendement du rapporteur monsieur
valtour le 749 qui est pour
qui est contre il est adopté je vous
remercie nous allons passer à
l'amendement 608 de Monsieur Clouet
propose de compléter de compléter
l'attention portée par l'accueil par les
Conseils territoriaux de santé sur la
prise en compte de l'expression des
usagers en précisant la nécessaire prise
en compte des usagers en situation de
handicap les situations de handicap
revête et je n'apprends rien à personne
des milliers de situations différentes
et nous attachons une importance toute
particulière à ne pas faire pour les
gens sans les gens car on fait toujours
contre les gens donc nous vous proposons
de faire mieux et d'intégrer les
personnes en situation de handicap dans
ces conseils territoriaux
je vous remercie monsieur le rapporteur
écoutez même raisonnement on a voté tout
à l'heure enfin l'amendement que j'ai
proposé qui permet de sans entrer dans
une liste trop longue mais de couvrir
l'ensemble des catégories de parties
prenantes au système de santé donc il me
semble pas utile de pousser cet
amendement qui me semble qui me semble
déjà servi donc je vous propose de le
retirer
merci donc je vais procéder au vote qui
est pour l'amendement 608
qui est contre
il est rejeté
madame minier
madame minier pour l'amendement 607 s'il
vous plaît madame le boucher merci
madame la Présidente alors partenam cet
amendement nous proposons de doter le
conseil territorial de santé en plus de
la commission spécialisée de santé
mentale de commission par spécialité
médicale en carence sur le territoire
l'exposé des motifs de cette proposition
de loi ont fait ouvertement Etat 25% des
médecins spécialistes couvrent 5% du
territoire une quarantaine de
départements sont aujourd'hui sous le
seuil critique de 40 spécialistes pour
100000 habitants certaines spécialités
sont plus touchées que d'autres
notamment à la psychiatrie la
gynécologie et la pédiatrie
le texte est donc que 23,6% des femmes
vivent dans un désert médical
gynécologique et 27,5% des enfants dans
un désert médical pédiatrique alors
puisque la proposition de loi se
contente de dresser le constat d'une
défaillance nous proposons que le
conseil territorial de santé se doit de
commission spécialisées représentant les
carences du territoire et son inégal
offre de soins afin de proposer des
pistes d'amélioration
je vous remercie monsieur le rapporteur
demande de retrait là aussi pour le même
le même raisonnement je pense que
l'intérêt de la démarche pardon de faire
confiance aux acteurs de terrain c'est
aussi qu'en fonction des besoins du
territoire et puis se doter des outils
les plus appropriés moi je sais pas si
dans le sud Bretagne on va avoir les
mêmes préoccupations que dans leur
Alsace ou je sais pas où donc à partir
de là dire les responsables de les
professionnels réunis les partis
prenantes réunis sont tout à fait aptes
à mettre en place ou seront apte à
mettre en place ces structures qui leur
semblent nécessaires je suis pas
favorable à rigidifier
effectivement le fonctionnement de ces
conseils territoriaux de santé donc je
vous propose de retirer cet amendement
d'autant plus je le redis qu'il est
servi et couvert par l'amendement que
nous venons de voter que j'ai présenté
il y a quelques minutes
merci monsieur le rapporteur monsieur
monsieur cloué excusez-moi je vous ai
pas vu je vous en prie madame la
Présidente alors je pense que le plus
n'est pas forcément l'ennemi du bien
donc si jamais c'est déjà ça satisfait
autant le satisfaire une deuxième fois
mais pour aller sur le fond de la
discussion qui s'ouvre vous nous dites
ici que vous ne voulez pas rigidifier un
dispositif nouveau or ce qu'on propose
ici c'est d'avoir des commissions qui
dépendent des spécialités médicales en
carence donc l'exemple que vous donnez
sur le sud Bretagne il trouve sa
résolution ici si jamais il y a des
carences et bien dès lors c'est un
moment permettra d'identifier et d'y
répondre s'il y en a pas et tant mieux
je le souhaite on y répondra pas et
c'est quelque chose qui est vraiment
fondamental je pense que de raisonner en
termes de pénurie et de manque
territoire par territoire par exemple si
on regarde enfin j'étais un petit coup
d'oeil sur doctolib avant dans vos
circonscriptions je sais que dans la
vôtre monsieur Valtou on peut avoir par
exemple le gynéco il peut avoir 8
rendez-vous d'ici à la fin de la semaine
dans celle de madame la Présidente c'est
4 et si on va dans le Gers par exemple
c'est 0
dans le mois et demi qui vient donc
résonner par le biais des spécialités
manquantes c'est le moyen d'introduire
le territoire non pas le rigidifiant
mais au contraire en posant les
conditions d'une prise en charge réelle
en fonction de ce qui existe et surtout
de voir ce qui n'existe pas pour y
répondre
merci Monsieur clou et monsieur le
rapporteur
mais j'entends ces arguments je
j'insiste sur un la souplesse 2 sur la
responsabilité des acteurs de terrain à
se doter de leur propre de la démarche
qui leur sont urgentes et qui
effectivement s'il peut y avoir un
problème de gynécologie quelque part si
vous tapez doctolib en cardiologie dans
ma circonscription vous n'aurez aucun
rendez-vous parce qu'il y en a pas voilà
donc vous voyez bon mais je pense que
les acteurs du territoire sont
suffisamment aptes à définir ces projets
territorial de santé c'est l'objet même
du projet territorial de santé où sont
les carences dans le territoire où sont
les leviers pour essayer d'agir et
comment on essaye collectivement d'agir
mais je veux dire c'est c'est l'essence
même de la démarche donc je le redis au
nom de la souplesse au nom de la de la
confiance faite aux acteurs de d'aller
sur les bons chemins et d'aller prendre
un bras le corps les bonnes priorités et
parce que l'amendement qu'on a qu'on
vient de voter
couvre l'ensemble du champ que vous
évoquez et ça me semble ça me semble
suffisant donc d'où ma demande de
retrait ou sinon de rejet
merci beaucoup donc je rappelle la vie
du rapporteur défavorable donc pour
l'amendement 607 s'il vous plaît 607
attendez que je mette au vote
qui est pour qui est pour
qui est contre
je demanderai à tout le monde de lever
les bras au que ce soit pour que ce soit
pour ou que ce soit contre merci il est
rejeté merci
et je voilà c'est bon vous pouvez
rabaisser vos bras je le demanderai pour
tous les autres votes parce que comme je
suis
située il y avait quelquefois j'ai des
bras qui qui engagent d'autres voilà
merci
alors Monsieur monsieur valtoux pour
votre
amendement 750 merci madame la
Présidente
du Conseil territorial de santé quand on
dit tout quand je disais tout à l'heure
effectivement donner du sens à tes
gouvernance territoriale donc le conseil
territorial de santé le projet
territorial de santé c'est très
important de le dire d'assurer le suivi
et l'évaluation de sa mise en œuvre en
lien avec l'agence régionale de santé
c'est pas les acteurs tout seul dans
leur coin bien sûr monsieur Daredevil
c'est aussi les services de l'État il
définira notamment les objectifs
prioritaires en matière d'accès aux
soins de permanence des soins et
d'équilibre territorial de l'offre de
soins et ceux qui sont je veux dire
attentifs à la lutte contre les déserts
médicaux apprécieront la portée de cette
dernière membre de phrase pour mener à
bien ses missions le comité le conseil
territorial de santé Satura sur un
bureau et cet organe exécutif organisera
les travaux du Conseil territorial de
santé pourra proposer des actions et
mettre en œuvre les décisions prises par
le Conseil territorial de santé
je vous remercie monsieur le rapporteur
donc nous allons procéder à notre
collègue monsieur Vigier vaudrait
[Musique]
il peut y avoir une difficulté parce
qu'il y a des territoires dans lesquels
il y a déjà des cptises qu'on fait des
programmes régionales de santé qu'on met
en place la permanence des soins qu'on
met en place toute cette politique qui
est préconisée par cette proposition de
loi donc en fait il faut qu'on trouve
une solution d'articulation parce que
sinon d'autres vont réécrire ce que les
premiers ont déjà fait oui mais dans
leur tête et quand ils vont voir arriver
un texte comme ça ils vont être
surpris pour certains qui sont partis
depuis quelques années qui vont voir
donc ce fameux conseil territorial qui
va arriver d'ici six mois un an ou 18
mois alors que beaucoup de choses ont
déjà été lancées en matière de
prévention je le disais en matière des
permanente des soins en matière des
passerelles avec l'hôpital donc je crois
qu'il faut que notre texte on peut pas
le faire tout de suite mais d'ici la
séance pour prévoir quelque chose pour
que lorsqu'il y a une structure qui est
fonctionnelle qui existe qui a fait ses
preuves et qui a conventionné avec la RS
et qui est financé par la RS pour faire
cela il est pas une dualité qui
s'organise et qu'au final il puisse y
avoir une techno structure incomprise et
qu'il soit démobilisante donc je tire la
tension du rapporteur pour qu'on trouve
le bon aboutissement d'ici la séance
monsieur d'arriville
oui merci madame la Présidente un peu
dans le même sens de ce que vient de
dire Philippe Vigier
un certain nombre de
d'acteurs se réunissent ou sont associés
dans dans l'hôpital pour écrire le
projet de hospitalier
dans dans les CPTs pour pour écrire un
projet territoire à l'échelle d'une CPTs
moi je dirais un peu les choses
autrement c'est à faudrait pas aussi qui
est une sorte de logique pyramidale qui
s'installe
et descendante je pense que pas
forcément votre intention je vous fais
pas ce procès monsieur rapporteur mais
je pense qu'il y a aussi quelques
pesanteurs qui peuvent exister quelques
habitudes quelques voilà on voit bien
comment parfois dans la manière dont
l'organisme l'administration s'organise
il y a ce type de logique qui se mette
en place et je pense que ça serait
problématique parce que si je comprends
bien ce que vous souhaitez c'est un peu
plutôt l'inverse voilà et moi je vois
par exemple il y a un certain nombre de
démarches qui se mettent en œuvre autour
de la santé environnementale dans la
CPTs une des deux CPTs de
massirconscription
il faudrait pas que tout ça soit
finalement désavoué par une autre
instance quoi
merci monsieur d'arriville
merci madame la Présidente oui ce que
j'entends est assez selon moi est assez
ahurissant nous assistons à la création
d'une treizième strat territoriale 13e
pas une de 3 13 à qui l'on va donner
exactement comme on a fait antérieure
territorialisation de la
décentralisation des prérogatives des
actions qui ont déjà été mises en place
par d'autres structures à qui on veut
actuellement je pense entre autres CPTs
donner encore plus de d'importance alors
je ne suis pas toujours d'accord avec
Monsieur Vigier mais pour une fois oui
je ne sais pas si lui appréciera mon
soutien je ne sais pas si Monsieur
dareyville appréciera mon soutien mais
effectivement on ne peut pas fonctionner
c'est évidemment évidemment pyramidal et
là nous assistons à une dérive
technocratique qui a fait que tout à
l'heure nous avons demandé la
suppression de l'article 1
merci Madame Mela donc je vais procéder
ah oui excusez-moi monsieur le
rapporteurville ensuite à Madame Melun
mais je confonds pas
l'ACPS qui est une organisation
principalement libérale et ce que sera
le conseil territorial de santé qui est
une organisation qui associera je le
redis les associations d'usagers les
collectivités locales les
administrations de la sécurité sociale
et l'État qui est vraiment l'endroit où
tout le monde discute qui est des CPTs
ces gens de chez moi j'en ai une qui
fait des projets aboutis parce que les
libéraux aiment travailler ensemble
madame Ménard sont pas tous dans une
logique d'individualisme forcené et
depuis longtemps et qu'à partir de là
que les CPD c'est déjà des projets c'est
une chose mais ça n'emporte pas
l'adhésion forcément des autres acteurs
les Hospitaliers les collectivités
locales et de ça je confonds pas les
choses et je pense que sans faire
pyramide pyramidale ou sans faire poupée
russe ou sans faire des des des choses
gères trop peu abstraites ou
bureaucratique c'est l'emboîtement des
projets quand on est sur le terrain et
je superpose pas la carte moi chez moi
dans mon territoire de santé a priori
j'aurais deux ou trois CPTs les libéraux
souhaitent avoir des petites structures
dans d'autres territoires les libéraux
aiment les grosses structures qu'est-ce
que vous voulez que
grand bien en face et donc je ne
superpose pas les choses et je ne
confonds pas les projets portés par les
libéraux entre eux qui sont intéressants
parce qu'ils sortent de la culture de
l'individualisme ou de l'approche un peu
individuel que par nature et leur métier
c'est tout c'est par nature a une
approche c'est-à-dire plus large
partagée avec les collectivités locales
les hôpitaux etc et des centres de santé
par exemple donc en fait tout ça n'est
pas posé dans mon amendement donc je
suis je reste favorable à mon amendement
si c'est la question que vous vouliez me
poser
alors Monsieur Vigier pour répondre
que des acteurs libéraux ils se trompent
nous nous avons mis tous les acteurs et
on a mis en place la permanence des
soins avec qui
hospitalier régulateur le SMUR donc en
fait les efflecteurs ils travaillent
après une régulation au fait par
l'hôpital public et donc qu'est-ce qui
va se passer c'est que j'entends son
amendement mais trouvons une
articulation une fois le plus
intelligente pour ce qui a été mis en
place ne soit pas démantelés ça non ça
risque de l'être et enfin c'est au
niveau des territoires de santé
j'entends son message comme quoi ils
peuvent être plus grands que des bassins
de vie je peux comprendre ou des bassins
de santé reconnu mais là aussi la
souplesse doit être mise 34% 37% du
territoire national est couvert je ne
crois pas une seule seconde qu'en six
mois on couvrira la France par
expérience donc si jamais n'est pas six
mois mais on met 12 mots voire 18 mois
et même c'est très volontaire de la part
du rapporteur de vouloir faire en sorte
qu'on structure que l'on soit capable
intelligemment de faire en sorte que ce
qui existe qui après l'épreuve ce qui
est régulée en plus et où là où en plus
on a des soins non programmés on n'aille
pas le fragiliser parce que j'ai peur
que ça soit la conséquence
merci Monsieur vigime c'est d'arriver
merci madame la Présidente je rejoins ce
rapporteur sur
l'idée que un lieu dans lequel se
réunissent l'ensemble des parties
concernés
c'est assez différent effectivement
d'une
CPTs etc je j'entends tout à fait cette
réalité il faut
il faut que l'ensemble des parties
puisse délibérer
mais mais la formule que vous proposez
elle soulève deux questions d'abord
celle du périmètre
sur lequel exerce ces conseils
territoriaux de santé et celui de leur
composition celle de leur composition
parce que du coup
la légitimité que prend la décision que
vous proposez de leur faire prendre
pourrait être discutable au regard de
tout cela moi par exemple il y a un
conseil de local de santé dans dans mon
coin
je pense qu'il y a dans ce lieu là qui
rassemble à peu près tout le monde quand
même des choses importantes qui se
disent et donc ça rejoint la remarque
que je faisais précédemment sur le
caractère possiblement pyramidal avec un
problème de légitimité qui à mon avis
pas tout à fait régler
merci Monsieur aura peut-être voudrait
rajouter quelque chose simplement les
questions qui sont évoquées et par
Pierre dareyville et par Philippe Vigier
sont tout à fait légitimes et montre
bien que la maturité des territoires est
très différente Philippe Vigier a la
chance d'être élu dans un territoire mur
ou les enfin murs les professionnels de
santé sont mûres et travaillent ensemble
on sait qu'il y a d'autres CPTs où les
libéraux exclu même de dialoguer avec
l’hôpital parce qu'il considère et la
loi ne leur donne pas tort que
que le CPTs est une institution à la
main des libéraux c'est quand je dis à
la main c'est une expression qu'on
entend souvent de la part de certains
libéraux et il faut leur laisser cette
légitimer là s'il le souhaite puisque de
toute façon c'est ce sont les textes
d'aujourd'hui et donc
voilà en fait
l'idée c'est que chacun s'organise un
peu comme il veut à partir du moment où
il respecte les intentions les priorités
qui sont fixées dans ce texte et si
demain il y a des
comics des conseils territoriaux de
santé qui rejoignent le périmètre d'un
CPTs qui a déjà son projet et veut faire
sien son projet personne ne les
empêchera et donc toute la souplesse
doit être donnée aux acteurs de
territoire j'y crois profondément
donc je vous propose je redis cet
amendement que je propose qui vise à à
bien placer le projet territorial de
santé comme moteur de la réflexion
collective et la démarche de la
stratégie collective c'est un amendement
il est important et je vous encourage à
le voter
vous voulez pour la dernière fois
rajouter
le mot silice les territoires sont
identiques on va pas créer de structures
et deux fois plus de réunion
pardonnez-moi enfin moi j'ai participé
pendant une année et demie à monter une
cités chez moi pour ceux qui veulent
venir voir c'est des réunions par mois
donc bonheur pour ceux qui vont faire
ensuite
merci je vais mettre l'amendement du
rapporteur 750 avec un avis favorable de
Monsieur valtour à porteur aux voix qui
est pour
enlève les bras là je vais pas répéter
qui est contre
il est adopté
il fait tomber
l'amendement 391 de Monsieur Benz et
l'amendement je parle que des présents
et l'amendement
394 monsieur Monet
suivant est un amendement de
coordination simplement
de coordination du rapporteur avec un
avis favorable de monsieur
valtoraporteur qui est pour
qui est contre
il est adopté madame Antoine est absente
hop tout ça aussi c'est ceux qui sont
tombés monsieur valtot une fois de plus
je mets aux voix un amendement avec la
vie favorable du rapporteur le 727 qui
est pour
qui est contre il est adopté